astrophysicist Neil deGrasse Tyson is
sharing his letter archive and revealing
his thoughts on everything from the
meaning of life to the existence of
Bigfoot his new book letters from an
astrophysicist contains more than 100
letters Facebook posts and other
exchanges with fans detractors and
family members Tyson is the director of
course of the Hayden Planetarium at the
American Museum of Natural History in
New York which is not far from where I
live it's a fabulous place good morning
welcome again good morning welcome back
I can't believe Gail Stallone owns an
iPod yes I do what that is the origin of
the word podcast so we have there you go
since since the last time you were here
you went through investigations into
three claims of sexual misconduct you've
retained your your jobs yes yes what I'm
what have you what have you learned in
the past year going through all this I
learnt to care about support that I've
received from friends and family from a
fan base that was there throughout the
entire time and a lot of that fan base
is sort of represented sort of
spiritually and emotionally and
intellectually in this collection of
letters where it's people sharing their
sort of deepest issues angst about the
world and all I'm saying is that in this
past year I'd learned to value that more
than ever before it was anything he
pointed out there were investigations
and you were cleared but I'm curious
about how the past year has changed you
were you surprised Neil that you were
even involved in a me-too allegation
people who know you and love you were
very surprised were you I you know the
life is you know day-to-day you don't
know what's gonna happen or who's gonna
say anything about anything what I do
know is that you people there's a
there's an understandable urge for
people to take sides to have opinions
even in the absence of information or
only partial information and the entire
point of an investigation is to be
thorough and to get to the bottom of
everything so it doesn't seem to
- for some people that doesn't matter I
suppose but for due process it matters
and greatly and first matter for just
the the effort to get to whatever the
truth that are out there you did right
in a public letter that's not in the
book that that the past year changed the
way you think about personal space and
that you would rethink it be a little
more sensitive in the future yeah I can
be yeah I mean it's yeah I have a lot of
sort of spillage of personality right
it's like so I I mean people the concept
of personal space has evolved over the
years and yeah but letters in the book
in terms of those I mean they really
spanned the range from from Big Foot to
letters to your father yeah yeah calling
him Tony a poopoo head one person wrote
in poopoo as an adult deeply apologetic
that when he was 10 he had accused me of
being in a poopoo head for demoting
Pluto yes and he said I deeply I'm sorry
I'm sorry to have hurt your feelings and
I now agree with what you said about it
but it was like a deadpan letter with
poopoo head in yes so that's in that
that exchanges in there you also hear
from climate sceptics and you talk about
how scientists can maybe communicate
better how so what K scientists do to
make people under your not trained to
communicate we're trained to be in the
lab and get our work done and so to
cross over can be awkward or difficult
or even impossible for many so we what's
important here is to at least have
analogies that people can relate to if
you have some ailment you go to a doctor
the doctor says here's a pill that 3% of
researchers say will cure you there's
another pill that 97% of researchers say
will cure you which pill you're going to
take you're gonna take the 97% so now
you have these very high agreement to
numbers for scientists warning about
this is called your most personal book
to date and I love how you talk to your
children in the book someone asks you
what do you teach your own children you
said you don't worry about what they
think as much as you you don't worry
about what they know as much as you
worry about what they think right it's
not so much what think about how they
think it's like when you see something
are you curious about it do you poke it
do you probe it and think about so much
how much effort
put in to try to keep a neat house yes
in the presence of guilty entropy
creating children yes and so no this is
the entropy they create the disorder of
the house is the consequence of them
being curious one common refrains from
when it comes to not cleaning the house
is the order of the universe goes from
order to disorder so I'm not gonna fight
that that's that's true no matter what I
want to ask you about the moon because
you got a letter from someone who told
you that they were disappointed after
listening to you bash the moon you used
a bashing I didn't bash the moon I just
said Mars was better
Mars oh how do you feel about NASA
aiming to take us back to the moon by
2024 I don't have a problem it you can
get there within a news cycle you get
there in three days you can rejuvenate a
public interest and yeah I want to send
people to Mars right so your be on the
moon at this point Oh moon
don't think of destinations think of the
solar system as our backyard yeah
the moment you start say I want to go
here instead of there that's the wrong
way to think about it one of the most
poignant things you brought in the green
room you came with show-and-tell today
yeah a letter that you wrote to your mom
and dad yes you did with calligraphy
calligraphy on parchment that's right
Wow yeah that was it was on their 30th
wedding anniversary yeah and I just
wanted to thank them for all the support
they had given me and my brother and
sister throughout our years once we
expressed an interest in our life's
ambitions they supported if they didn't
they'd never supplanted that with either
their lost dreams or whatever they Neil
deGrasse Tyson says true love of
learning never ends for somebody who's
worried about their GPA GPA if you
become if you leave school as a lifelong
learner your GPAs couldn't be less
relevant to your life existence of alien
life oh sure worried that they you know
we just had comic-con a few days ago
yeah I worried that they might have
landed during comic-con and no one knows
you know bad luck